[Music]
in sixth sense news Padamsee that fast
example X 6 mm 6 & 6 & 6 7
likes perfect pocket change no likes and
like the movie um yeah I see ghosts how
many senses are there ok what are the 10
name isn't there 5 I presume I'm right
there's a touch there's a taste there's
a feel there's a see there's an ear so
what's the fear no it's whatever it is
that's like that's like see dead people
or feel I don't know how animals feel
there's taste no he really touch okay
submitted by where do babies come from
done a vagina
storks Oh which one's the real one
all right India is a blindfolded wonder
boy can allegedly see with his mind
after years of brain training who is
this blindfolded wonder boy how do you
see with your mind
and what's in his brain gyro turn I just
want to fart you haven't trained though
yeah he trained with the crisper yeah
what's his training like so 17 year old
Jeep Trivedi I like the name GGG so he
has been doing this thing called
midbrain activation training cool and so
I do that [ __ ] all the time with
marijuana what have you learned
movies are different yeah when you watch
it without sure yeah so apparently this
midbrain activation thing is really
popular in India and like it seems that
it's mainly geared for children to learn
this it's just like one of those kind of
like is really a real thing why do you
want to learn it I still don't
understand what is a midbrain training
okay so it's a pseudo scientific
practice that is supposed to activate
the midbrain to Venice to the benefit of
gaining certain normal
and supernormal abilities in all my
years of psychology and neuroscience and
all that [ __ ] I don't even know what the
[ __ ] a midbrain is I've never how do
they define midbrain is this corpus
callosum
you know midbrain is the medulla abakada
it's not Meza look mess and cessful own
messes mr. Cephalon that's that still
does it that's just a Latin way of
seeing midbrain it still doesn't explain
anything
we're just saying ya Hossein midbrain or
it's also called Swiss so it's a portion
of the central nervous system associated
with vision hearing motor control sleep
wake arousal alertness and temperature
regulation so everything but which part
the mid the midbrain like your mid body
long enough for fingers to hear is there
another word for it they have they
haven't defined enter let me see that's
what there's a wiki page you think so
the midbrain connects every sense this
is the midbrain
well there's parts to it so I'm trying
to figure out which part it is is
associated with vision hearing I guess
it's because I'm saying our mid body
okay we'll all right I'm on my lungs my
pancreas my liver on my kidney
let us like the limbic system but the
midbrain comprises the tectum tegmentum
and the cerebral aqueduct and the
cerebral peduncles head on forehead
uncle right a little bit on our head and
cut part yeah well I wanted to do this
brain activation
yeah I can pedal so that's what the
midbrain is and so this kid Jeep he
apparently does a lot of
blindfold or he does a lot of activities
blindfolded and so I'm going to show you
guys a video of some of the stuff that
he has done
and so apparently he's justhe's
wonderboy but I think he's pulling a
Josh and obscured pictionary she's
backing off oh I can't see anything
meeting that's going so funny
although until after the video here we
go oh if the History Channel does it it
trail around
Wow what were the oxygen I need to tell
you who might be mustard Tiffany vehicle
Nikolai Gonzaga I wouldn't touch back Oh
crazy I just thought of her new Jackie
party balloon isn't it Wow
never mind yeah I really am hi Russell
destroy because one time you should
focus really young punk look that's ugly
down at night off is August 1941 degree
the date of the eighth everything what
they needed dews of the book behind them
why did it Brian how we memorize this
what is he doing
also right here here's a light bulb and
a tail and he dropped a life of its own
like what how the dollar forget that is
impressive
what kind of until we try it it always
does that
I'm light bulb I mean we got to try it
to figure out who know what is the towel
was broken before that I think it'd be a
setup
yeah all a sudden DSN up like he's doing
magic
wow that was like magic yeah I don't
trust any of them have you guys heard of
the incredible Randy he's a skeptic in a
magician I really like him and there's a
back in the day like before we were even
born he had a TV show and then he said
like any of you
magic [ __ ] I will give you a million
dollars if you come on to my show and do
some supernatural ass [ __ ]
and then everyone that came he debunked
all of them and [ __ ] MIT like showed
what type of frauds they were and it was
crazy things magical Randy
of the incredible Randhir some justice
that I like him he looks like a gay
Santa Claus yeah so apparently G is
saying that anyone can do this anyone
can do what he does as long as you just
train your midbrain know if it's true
that's pretty cool but it just looks too
phony when they're like this the whole
time I guess this trait duct-taped his
face or they put the book behind them
yeah or instead of a blindfold actually
put like stickers that was really good I
[ __ ] doing birth yeah it's like Josh
Bible dictionary blindfolded Josh oh my
god I can't believe he cheated on that
game the time of year is I have gone
over sorry we were playing blindfolded
pictionary and I think it was Gio who
said Josh that is too perfect
he's actually knew it was you I knew it
was it came from a Latin mouth the first
I whispered sabar because he was right
next to me I'm like I can't think he can
because look partying say yeah what is
that
oh thank you and as he was drawing I was
like look he connected that line to that
line like he was over here and he went
back hearing he connected that elevate
you could see in another warrant that is
a chef I didn't know gibberish super
simple yet what the order of which he
drew was too perfect because once you
let your pen off yeah there's no [ __ ]
way you will continue at that part right
Wow I think you know he didn't know
exactly where that Plus right in the
middle you got the arrow right where it
should be you drew the book you know
exactly the plus on you add your eyes
open this whole time don't even like
you're saying you the chair yes oh oh no
I don't you bet we do you broke my heart
Josh
he broke my heart I mean when you was
called out he was like I thought we were
playing obscured pictionary like
obscured vision like where you could see
just a little bit you see good guys and
enforcement to cover eyes oh my god you
cheat bad Josh he's just so sweet and
innocent he just didn't know the rules
we'll just leave it at that but yeah so
it seems like this kid in my personal
opinion I'm a skeptic I'm like you're
just playing obscure pictionary over
here what if he was like Josh I'm not
we're playing obscured midbrain
[Laughter]
would it be 17 other face is pretty
genius to be a fraud a young age be 17
you wouldn't mind introducing adults
another standard oh yeah he has his mind
training teacher so like his teacher is
also involved with like his son this
camp we have videos of the teacher
there's a partner yeah you know what
would be like completely impressive is
if he was blind because I remember we
watch this one blind kid that was able
to play video games and beat his friends
what oh yeah a roller skate I thought
this guy was blind
oh yes I was like why don't we just look
at his eyes you know blind people like
their I'll be all cloudy and [ __ ] like
why don't we just season oh then yeah
[ __ ] this kid so what do you ever say
this whole thing first full of the only
person that would fall for this and go
to their school would be Michael Michael
really my alter the oldest trick in the
book
oh yes would be something like up being
in Jared twice twice oh my mom's would
fall for [ __ ] like this - we keep
software why is he yeah so the first
time he he won I think and then they're
like alright let's just do it again and
then he played that same hand and then
he lost yeah he trying to get his money
back is the first one he won his money
is ten dollars
I'm an excellent he put in like 50 or
something to double
that's when he took his money yeah yeah
at the scene other hero business yeah he
lost 60 euros Michael should not travel
alone have you traveled alone all the
time yeah oh yeah he told me that story
he said that they just took his money
and says that's my money now
and I felt like he just couples lead us
from a bully that just took his lunch
money and just walked away yeah because
I think I would probably start crying
really loud really loud like really
really loud yeah and then like I would
make them like really guilty yeah
because I mean like if there's like six
Russian dudes that are really like hairy
and strong like I don't know man like I
gotta be realistic I got to either bite
them and then do something crazy like
you know like you got to use tactics you
got to be realistic here there's no
[ __ ] hero moment I'm a 5 7 asian guy
these guys are like 6 foot Eastern
Europeans or maybe like African refugees
I don't know they also said you would
fight you would bite them instead of
just walking away yeah but I mean
there's a I have pride I cannot walk
away from that situation I am NOT the
bigger man here I'm [ __ ] petty thing
you should just do this like the table
they run yes I want to somehow
traumatize them know that I'm going to
either cry and make a big [ __ ] scene
and like really make their lives like
really hard and embarrass them the whole
way everybody something you know or I
will go the other route and make them
regret ever [ __ ] with me I would
diarrhea in front of them running all
over the [ __ ] clothes like you can't
come in there diarrhea just like that oh
yeah I got IBS girl [ __ ] in each car
yeah I mean like I can't just watch them
like I'm not gonna fight every single
one of them if there's like six guys
dude I gotta use teeth I'm scratching on
pokey eyes I'm fighting nuts like I'm
[ __ ] pulling their shoes off and
throwing it over so they'll go run for
it like I'm doing crazy [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] with Joe hope you guys
enjoyed that video but if you didn't
guess what you
directly contribute to the articles that
we discuss just cruise out over to the
description box below click on that link
to submit your article also for the next
video click right up hi